[Musique]
il aurait couché à phoenix celui mais
trop tard pour l'histoire alors on est
et où déjà chaque soir au moment de
l'endormir
le père de sofia devient le prince d'un
monde merveilleux inventé pour elle
et chaque soir
j'arrive protège le train sauve sa
princesse
jusqu'au jour où comme on n'a pas
d'histoire
papa j'ai raison on est parti seul mon
histoire mon cul tu comprends c'est la
fin mon pote ou alors plaque ce monsieur
pouvait pas rentrer le prince va arriver
je suis le prince il a un fond
les princes
segosa
mon père a toujours été très présent
mais un certain âge j'aimais bien qu'ils
me laissent un petit peu d'air
les oubliés c'est là où on en voit les
personnages quand ils sont plus dans
aucune histoire
et disparaît
trop de monde welcome to the oubliette
expliquer ça c'est tout moi je viens pas
me dis que c'est ton frère
ses connaissances lui que vous êtes un
super papa il faut bien la laisser
grandir
bloqués ici et donc très sensible
et toutes ces histoires leur profil est
rempli
cependant chez fogiel
[Musique]
ici la police de l'école
tous les ouvriers sans oublier de vous
offrir pour se faire identifier
nous demandons dont on les rues ciel les
manoirs du corps maintenant
en plus je vais m comment des gardiens
autorisée
maintenant le visage pour que les folles
j'ai besoin d'un électrique
moi je suis un électrique aurait pu
prendre un autre contrat démonté dans la
vanne pourquoi on veut savoir avec qui
il collabore
[Musique]
ma mère est malade j'ai besoin d'argent
ok on va voir ce que tu peux faire
il est doux et on électrique or il sait
pas quel point encore d'allumer là il va
falloir que je le tour
comment tu veux vivre cette année c'est
partie cachée des pouvoirs oublie ça et
si tu vois quelque chose que tu veux à
leurs problèmes on surveille un
électrique qui pourrait être lié à
plusieurs thèmes déjà exécution
tu t'es retrouvé mêlé à des affaires pas
d'elle
si tu franchis ceci ne reviendra pas non
non si je la perds qu'elle n'aurait plus
rien toute façon on a un autre contrat
pour toi
et tu n'aura qu'une chance
qu'est ce qu'on fait si leur action
couper facilement je vais réussir
il va réussir
[Musique]
de fait quand même produit
moi pas tu as vu ma fille tu as vu le
format il ya des gens calmes se forme à
tout le monde et par an à 4
bon allez faut que je me mette une
petite boîte la bible au pardon non dit
et j'ai cru et ses terrains un petit sac
de sable aléas plus vraiment si je veux
vraiment je mets un legging un brushing
il est à moi le gars ça ne mérite pas
tout ce temps j'ai offert un enfant qui
a rouvert mais je sens que tu as envie
quelques tôt ce pas
sensuelle
n'abandonne jamais
tu prends ça tu t'entraînes tranquille
je suis là je bouge pas enfin alors
nourri toi quand même parce que ça peut
prendre du temps cette histoire
[Musique]
mais ça tombe bien le web agri mais le
tuer car il faut que tu vois deux camps
d'al yah ils font du cac et montures
c'est quoi ce bordel
on a tous voila connard tu as failli me
tuer ma femme tuée mais j'ai pas fais il
a dit que j'appelle à bas coûts on va
répondre aux questions elle a craqué la
mise en plis ou quoi la caisse à toi tu
as un problème c'est pas ça une tête de
gland tu as envie de prendre une branlée
vous vous calmez aller qu'on s'engueule
attentes autour soit j'arrivais décembre
colin soir je vais trois pans de moi
nolwenn à cri mais de quoi
à tanger par ailleurs fortis
[Musique]
ok on va y aller lancer la procédure
d'activation
procédure lancée vas-y à 112
je m'entends bien mais d'abord vous
veillez choisir ma voix celle du vieux
pirate
le test est donné cher il a visiblement
besoin d'importantes modifications
j'aimerais savoir ce que représentent
ces faux plat sur le nom c'est notre
famille je fais partie de votre famille
robot s'est échappé eh bien c'est la
cerise sur le gâteau et pourquoi c'est
déguisé
aujourd'hui c'est pas halloween et qui
es-tu je suis un robot sauveur
multifonctions en fait tu ressembles
puis ça en clown
c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas tort ce rebond
constitue une menace et d'être
neutralisé
le fait par idiot on est de la même
famille maintenant
maintenant on est des amis et que
deviendra robot s'il le retrouve
je crains qu'ils soient démontées
non c'est pas vrai alors vas-y
mon statut
tu imagines devenir ami avec notre fille
il te faudrait remonte lui sans fin ro
ferait pas de mal à une mouche il s'est
échappé du labo il a des problèmes de
communication il n'est pas dangereux et
il n'y a aucun problème
nous allons le mettre hors d'état de
nuire non il a changé
on cherche des vêtements et une moto
aussi c'est ça non nul besoin
je suis plus rapide attraper
oui n'ont rien des vêtements
[Musique]
sergio des mélos le réparateur du monde
je crois
bonjour à tous levés vous connaît
rapprochez-vous représentant de l'onu le
plus puissant de l'histoire
la question c'est que faire de tous
pouvoirs
les vrais défis sont sur le terrain
[Musique]
c'est là-bas que les gens souffrent là
bas qu'on a besoin de vous
bush va vouloir que tu ailles en irak
t'es pas le seul diplomate qui peuvent
envoyer quelqu'un d'autre c'est pas
facile pour moi
pas du tout je veux voir ce pays
indépendant cette mission nous force à
donner le meilleur
ça a pas l'air très accueillants on est
à bagdad six radios
tu pourras toujours qu'on pourra s'en
aller au bout de quatre mois toujours
vous m'entendez ça va en bas nom de dieu
vous êtes sérieux des mélos vous vois
pas ce qui s'est passé je sais ce que je
veux faire de ma vie ces radios là
maintenant qu'est ce que tu veux
rassemblons ensemble ce qu'on sait sur
l'occupation rend sa public
vous ne pouvez pas faire ça à sergio
vous êtes là pour nous aider
c'est la seule raison de votre présence
la seule raison de ma présence c'est
parce que vous avez brisé ce pays et que
vous n'avez aucune idée comment le
remettre en état
est ce que l'onu sert de couverture à
l'occupation américaine epa suggéré une
seule seconde qu'on est là pour soutenir
les états unis où la coalition
on s'endort pas ok j'ai deux survivants
au moins sauvé on n'a plus beaucoup de
temps
ils ne viendront plus pourtant évacuer
la zone immédiatement il faut que je le
retrouve
[Musique]
à redon d'arriver si tard moselle vient
pas de manière à témoins suite nous
avons dû libérer votre suite libéré ma
suite vous l'avait relâché dans la
nature
il semble que vos notes ne nous est pas
été réglés
maman s'établit à eur pas tout de suite
maintenant celle ci ce sont les autres
ils ont besoin nos foyers
leur mère si sa tante et son besoin
on va tout de même pas laisser la plus
grande star du monde sans rien à boire
frank sinatra et qui si franck est
génial mais il n'est pas judy garland
j'ai plus de maison même du mal à
trouver un à presque rien si tu portais
à londres puis serait grassement payés
tu veux dire qu'il faudrait que je
quitte mes enfants si je veux gagner
suffisamment d'argent pour élever mes
enfants
j'aimerais tellement rester quelqu'un
avec joly il ya des centaines de gens
qui sont venus vous entendre chanter ma
bouche et tout sèchement landry germées
écoutez moi je vous ai dit non ça va
bien c'est sûr que ça va aller à voir si
je serai le refaire
ouais devriez apprendre à faire
attention à vous on attendait tous notre
part tout moment et j'ai eu l'année
[Applaudissements]
j'ai les mêmes rêves que la plupart des
gens juste plus de mal à les atteindre
[Musique]
faites quelque chose contre la
dépression j'ai fait quatre mariages
peut conclure nous sommes
vous n'oubliez pas
m
connectez vous
mesdemoiselles mesdemoiselles un petit
là s'il vous plaît pendant les deux
années que nous avons passées ensemble
l'institution ménagères vanderbeek de
vos futurs professeurs et moi même à
nous avons la délicate mission de faire
de vous la perte des ménagères rotation
toujours dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre la bonne épouse est avant
tout la compagne de son mari ce qui
suppose oubli de soi et une bonnes
moeurs
rhett et tout devenait dingue au 24 ans
de vie commune c'est quoi ce fameux cds
puis si je prendrais tous imprimés
passer la seconde
femme au volant mort au tournant tuapati
matois aussi alors il est
les sens et que nous arriverons à sauver
l'école que nous devrions nous vous
compte
je voudrais un carnet de chèques
bon épouse se concentre sur ses tâches
ménagères tu veux te voir
afin de ne pas céder à toutes ces
tentations de moore n'a occupé mauvaises
pensées chasser l'air et diamant fer
qu'elle a monté à paris rouge en effet
ministre les quoi féministe c'est qui
ces femmes qui veulent être les égales
des hommes ont fait des dépôts niche
comme vous je me vivre où je vais et
qu'il est prêt je pas toujours le scalp
de faire ma vie avec toi
si ça peut te rassurer ceux que je suis
à l'aise du repassage et supprimer les
cuisiner tu sais faire la cuisine toi
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes bien chez la famille
price si vous voulez joindre à temps
corrigeons maura ya laissé un message
après deep in vous n'étiez pas obligé de
rester avec elle
est-ce qu'on se connaît elle a dit
qu'elle était tombée enceinte et ensuite
elle a perdu le bébé c'était pas vrai
elle a jamais été enceinte elle vous a
menti je t'aime tellement
est-ce que tu assimilés de grossesse ce
que je fais aujourd'hui
ceux qui disent la vérité crue
écoute moi ce n'est pas ce que tu penses
il y a autre chose en jeu je crois
qu'elle est à la maison on sort heures
comment tu peux ne pas savoir où elle
est toi tu le sais peut-être j'écoute je
sais que vous deux ça n'avait pas très
fort depuis un certain temps quoi tu
sais peut-être un truc que je sais pas
une chaussure la parité ap jusqu'aux
événements d'août et des renforts le
trousseau de clés de votre femme a été
trouvé sur les lieux
ça n'a absolument aucun sens
elle se pointe mystérieusement et elle
balance une bombe sur la vie des gens
pour les [ __ ] en l'air et ensuite
disparaît c'est une blague ou quoi je
peux pas papa soit au courant de ça je
veux que tu me promettent d'arrêter ce
business tout fait qu'est-ce que vous
avez ta mère et toi à fourrer votre nez
tant de nos athlètes non vous savez que
c'est une menteuse personne ne voulait
que c'est voulu comme ça comment va-t-on
adorable femme
nous n'avons donc plus rien d'un outil
il a dit qu'il fallait l'arrêter
il faut que je la trouve
on a tous nos petits secrets enfouis
quelque part y compris toi
[Musique]
une